and I'm David and we're here to review
x-men Days of Future past
directed by Bryan Singer who directed
the first two x-men arguably the best of
the x-men movies especially the second
one which is kind of a masterpiece of
superhero story yes so going into this
there's gonna be some spoilers there are
absolutely gonna be any spoilers this is
a movie that you want to see like the
spoilers are pretty awesome so a
favorite moments let's just use favorite
moments Bryan what was the best um there
were a few favorite moments everybody I
mean the Quicksilver moment oh yeah for
sure the heist is is absolutely it's
really stunning I don't know how like I
would love to know how they did it I
just like it's so well done yeah
honestly I think this is kind of a
masterfully made movie including the
screenwriting and the structure of it
there's a moment at the end where things
are culminating perfectly and intensely
in the future as well as in the past and
it's really incredible the way that it
organically lets those two stories kind
of come to a head at the same time and I
thought that that was really amazing of
especially Simon Kinberg the
screenwriter yet to combine so many
characters and so many worlds and
different movies I mean between the
spin-off of Wolverine and then x-men
origins who no one really don't want
likes that movie and then the thanks
meant first class and then you have all
these sort of time loops I mean from a
craftsmanship point of view like the
screenwriters did a great job of
combining everyone and getting everyone
into consistent story and also a really
nice job of there are some as with every
time travel movie there's some kind of
things that don't match up but I think
for the most part they do a good job of
establishing the rules of this
time-traveling world and kind of
sticking to them now the rules are a
little convoluted yeah but I think the
argument could be made that they stuck
to them um let's talk a bit about the
cast that's a huge thing
yeah um there has been this huge kind of
like hub of about how they got both
casts together and it is like really
amazing that they got this many people
in a movie there it's not so much you
know it's not like all 20 cast members
are in the same scene all the times at
that depth there's basically two
different worlds you have the future and
then you have the 19:7
and the 1970s are a great period piece
they they really keep building the
relationship of xavier and erik lensherr
so well oh yeah
and like you said the way that a lot of
techniques are kind of like sewn
together like they have the millimeter
film stock they have the Quicksilver
sequence which is really a tour de force
in terms of fast motion slow motion and
things like that
a lot of the techniques that he uses to
convey Xavier is telekinesis things like
that
for me Bryan Singer really really
obviously knows this world really well
and he has full control of the world
yeah I especially think he does a great
job directing the actors because I like
the city of James McAvoy talking to
Patrick Stewart you basically have the
same character talking to themselves and
I just think that's an amazing scene I
thought that that was really strong and
again with mystique Jennifer Lawrence
really does an amazing job and not just
I mean she's obviously an amazing
actress but the the physicality of the
role is is obviously very telling and
she is incredible with it she embodies
it in every single scene she's kind of
the centerpiece of because when he
thought when I saw x-men in 2000 like
who would have thought mystique would be
this big character throughout the next
like all the x-men movies I mean I don't
think anyone planned it that way and
that's maybe the weakness with these
movies is they weren't planned one by
one by one the same way Marvel is
playing in the cinematic universe yeah I
think this movie does a great job of
tying everything together so well I mean
so we see a lot of nuke mutants in this
movie such as Bishop warpath blink who
is basically inspired by the portal
videogame she is a character from the
comics she had a few appearances in the
90s but they used her power very very
awesome
yeah the visual effects are amazing the
only disappointment really is that you
don't see enough of it but of course the
movies budget was 220 million or
something yeah they can't keep going I
mean the portal aspects were so well
done the Sentinels look awesome
four of the new x-men we see such as
Bishop we don't get much backstory
yeah and storm I really liked in the
movies and she really doesn't do much in
this so they were disappointed about
that there is a feeling that with the
scheduling and stuff like oh we can have
Halle Berry for three days like yeah
that kind of thing David I love this
movie yeah I loved it too it's
kudos x2 that was definitely my favorite
it's it's probably the best of the x-men
movies it's just so clever like visually
stunning we saw an IMAX 3d just so
that's awesome so you even the biggest
screen possible yeah really rad I'm
absolutely gonna buy this on blu-ray and
this movie is awesome
go see it and if you've seen already
comment below let us know what you
thought until next time I'm Ryan and I'm
David thank you for watching